I couldn't see myself with anybody else
so he's like literally the love of my
life and that's that's in Maksim
Chmerkovskiy
and Peter Murgatroid are getting married
so to celebrate their nuptials et is
running down their 7 cutest moments as a
couple
can we see this sparkler hold it up for
the camera for us max pop the question
during a live dance performance in
December 2015 at the end of the day we
just love each other and that's that's
the bottom line going along with that
whole dance thing they put their sexiest
moves on full display during a romantic
trip to st. Maarten in March 2016
[Music]
their PDA is off the charts this duo
literally cannot keep their hands off
each other yeah it's a great feeling
then the baby announcement in June 2016
Peter shared their heartwarming
pregnancy reveal on Instagram throughout
Peters pregnancy the duo proved time and
time again just how excited they were to
become parents max even mastered the art
of diaper changing no it's supposed to
be super simple max the PETA's bundle of
joy arrived January 4th a boy named Shai
the couple waited nearly two months
before giving fans a glimpse of their
adorable son but when they finally did
it was pretty obvious just how happy
they were as a family
[Music]